Super Mario Super Mario Super Mario
World Super Mario World
it's a blast from Japan it's super mario
world overly right Super Mario Brothers
not everyone knows that I'll gather the
Super Mario World show where they behave
men for some reason you know we always
harp everyone outside this movie for
like the dumbass plot bad hands but when
you think about like super mario world
suddenly like there's cavemen it's like
why what i guess cuz we have dinosaurs
but they weren't around anyway at the
same time so it makes no sense
I barely remember that shit I just
remember there at the Koopa Kids where I
remember the shaken Mario Brothers 3
show and of course the original Super
Mario Brothers Super Show which is
probably the words like they're all
awful anytime a new game came out there
was a show to go with it so bad you are
to others remember we do they have a
Nintendo the series oh yes
Super Mario Bunch Nintendo with the
Zelda crush hey Joe fans Oh ed than ever
lyrics likely Rebecca lyrics is OK
it's a cereal now Nintendo
it's a cereal wow they changed a letter
in that goes up like after Nintendo oh
let's talk about everyone's always like
Oh Nintendo whatever it is this has been
that great lately and stuff like that
but it's like where there's a time when
Nintendo just did games and sucked at
everything else and this was on light
now question yeah what at least they're
not allowing movies and shows oh um oh
but then that guy is I could we want see
like whatever that Netflix is elder or
whatever I was I guess it was just a
rumor but like shit we've been amazing
oh boy there's like no that is way too
awesome we would never have our hand in
it so let's talk about the Super Mario
Brothers movie oh wait uh Kiki get your
zone together vote Koopa who are the
other options in that movie isn't it
vote koopa boca the pool house was
running good i mean
all the rush room King right yeah which
he liked took over and turned into
fungus anyway so what was the political
did he just put it up so that newcomers
coming or like oh he must have won
what's in Kazakh let's be honest the
political structure of the Mushroom
Kingdom never made much sense to begin
with yeah there's no he's a princess
never a cake you're crazy this this but
this kingdom goes through governments
more than Italy okay like every other
week there's another invasion the
monarchy is overthrown a tyrant is
installed the I mean what is their
budget there's bottomless pits
everywhere says the pothole problem that
needs to be fixed
this whole kingdoms in disarray it's not
even worth saving
I don't know why Mario keeps following
this is it is the Gary Indiana of
kingdoms it's just just just let it go
we're gonna get so weak emails from
Italy and Gary Indiana um so but yeah
Gary in the end I can deal with it Elyse
kisses this this is a movie that I think
you like in terms of how bad it is more
than I do I can see it as all artists
but you legitimately get and let me let
me let me make this let me make this
perfectly clear this is for me
a classic guilty pleasure movie if you
ask me there's like defend this movie
I'll be like nobody can't know it now
nobody can I mean it's just it's not
good but if you're just like do you
enjoy this movie yes cuz it is just so
dumb well it was so silly silly stupid
dumb and a lot of that it really gets
spread kind of evenly around amongst the
three leads it's it's Bob Hoskins trying
his damndest
yeah I'm basically doing these and
apparently as T added later yeah drunk
off his ass basically just recycling his
Eddie valiant accent from Roger Rabbit
is that Mario way it told Roger what
yeah you got John Leguizamo who just
that I don't know if he's drunk or high
as a guy but he's just like he doesn't
care he's like woo and the Dennis Hopper
who just is like definitely high as a
kite Dennis Hopper is the original kind
of Christopher Walken where it's like
you don't know what he's I think
we said that like you don't know what
he's gonna do today it's not acting yeah
yeah what he's gonna do today well
between the three of them and just the
fact that this plot is so bad shit crazy
even for Super Mario Brothers I love
this movie you know and the fight thing
is like that my dad was saying for years
cuz when we were growing up we sort of
saw and we're told des Hopper was like
this dignified director and actor and
stuff like that and he was saying it's
so funny because for years people just
saw him as like a fucking pothead you
know I'm Easy Rider had a following
Beau's not like this classic that
everybody sees now thanks Eddie Mario
Brothers brought that bad ya know it
kind of is because what we saw right
well what is Dennis Hopper doing it that
you know what I must be 12 or 13
whatever what's those up for doing at
this I thought it's like this dignified
actor and yeah just go Mac to give you
know Deb my art damn it's just like
that's just kind of how I'm used to
seeing you naked I thought this around
we saw but then what's this dignified
thing but it's like they didn't see it
which is kind of like the Robin Williams
stretch where you did the darker films
for a while and then started going back
to things like Night at the Museum and
the crazier movies and so if you had
just grown up only with Robin Williams
in like Good Will Hunting huh you'd be
like what the hell is this
it's just like but you know fortunately
we we got crazy Dennis Hopper well okay
so jelly goes Almo did a video whenever
like the 10 or 20th anniversary of Super
Mario Bros and really wouldn't lie just
a little like be like they just say you
know thanks to everyone who enjoyed it
it was a such a blast filming and stuff
and it's like he looks here that to all
the other interviews he's done where
both him and ha skis just ripped this
fucking film a new one and he was like
apparently really encouraged to downplay
his improv like no way prom at all which
by god this movie could have used some
improv that's true
I you know I only the only the really
only funniest bit the funny bits out of
those two are just from their quote
unquote acting it's up from their lines
the only funny lines come from Dennis
Hopper yeah and that's a little bizarre
um Goomba
Oh Goomba join the other Goomba you
later alligator
monkey but the best Bob on is really
funny but the mom was my favorite Mouse
cousin so what we ha ha monkey is my
favorite cuz it looks like he just
entered his second childhood like
there's the gates of his childhood
opening up and it's like all you had to
do is say the word monkey to get he's
just like monk like he's about to cry
saying that he is about to cry when he
said that works it was just so beautiful
the monkey was so beautiful I still that
that was I remember that was the one job
that I wanted was uh how you could see
his career imploded the second he says
Baba yeah like this wonderful moment
where and I still stand by that that
everything that is Dennis hoppers career
just explodes in this nuclear mushroom
cloud of amazing what the fuckin s see
and I thought right when he says Oh C
then we disagree because I thought it
was that monkey so we could put a boat
together and put Academy award-nominated
after uh so yeah I need for me of this
first of all I mean we really should
start from the beginning when we saw the
trailer for this because there is no
video game movies at all the trailer
from is not the fucking I got the power
one that one's bullshit the one that
starts off like uh you know with it
raining and the woman dropping off the
baby and there's koopa in the rain
turning with his military outfit got
spikes and stuff lights like this and
it's like well what is this what's going
on eight what how long's metal sign
that's kind of cool no no what the game
I'm like okay what like the Stallone
films or something like things like you
know where's the rock the plumber stuck
in and you're like what he's like oh man
who could it be
and I like this big metal siding goes
super motherfucking Mario Brothers it
didn't actually say motherfucking but it
might as well cuz it's like that's right
kids we made a habit and it's like
Batman it's like the Michael Keaton
Batman of Super Mario probably imagine
this is named Louis's 1992 well yeah
something like that
1890 to everybody in the cinema even
like adults that grew up playing on
there
no like just erupting it was like heads
if little kids heads could explode it
would have and then you just and you see
there they are
no don't red and the green and they got
these buddies it's mixed up a little bit
you got these middle uh boots that make
them jump up into the air and then you
got Dennis Hopper Cooper that's weird
but whatever he's got fucking player
always with the lumbars other jumping
through that it's just like Super Mario
Brothers I don't like sitting in mad
bags yeah everybody was just charged
with adrenaline it was just an amazing
trailer for what it was the it was kind
of like it was the world combat trailer
it was kind of like that reboot of
Planet of the Apes that was awful but
the trailers sewn together will be like
wow okay oh my god I'm kind of I wish
even and it's like it really was just
like you know on paper it shit and in
the final uh delivery of it it shit but
in those trailers you're actually kept
this could work this could work and uh
yeah than that that opening happens with
that horrible animation and it's like
this is not a movie you fuck it every
time so I yeah you a bunch of dinosaur
simple wooden things wait wait just
don't get it no better to take you with
you guys shows you didn't do it I'm just
like what's like I know I remember I
just I remember looking at you just kind
of like hmm this is kind of awkward like
in everybody like there was this awkward
silence cuz I get opened I remember like
there was kind of like this applause
there were a bunch of kids there yeah we
have all right music oh yeah and like
everybody areas like yeah psyche there's
like what's like fuckin Lord of the
Rings that's like in the day and yeah
then that opening
damn you get blinky dang it shows like
you could just hear a pin drop this is
just like no talking if there's this
kind of like Americans don't have human
have creature dinosaurs that were there
is no no now they're these uh Mario
Paint cartoons that sound like Mario you
workers in a retirement home it's funny
cuz are don't jerk no bears Mario Paint
yeah Mario Paint could have done better
I mean we're talking about okay at this
stage in the game we had NeoGeo was out
there somewhere turbo graphics 16 you
had Super Nintendo and uh and Genesis
and almost all of those really could
have eclipsed the graphics we saw
anything in that movie that's what made
it embarrassing I'm just like you know I
could play something that looks better
than this maybe wouldn't have full voice
but I could play something that looks
better than we got impact them the
effects for this we're not only but seen
as good that they were creative they
were like cool ideas to have you know
see test hoppers face disappearing in
the sand going hahahahaha it's like
what's the fun of this leads up to that
I mean just was the guzzle post like
Terminator 2 kind of a business GG I was
still in that stage of like the t1000
was really cool we hadn't seen a lot
like that yet yeah and they were really
having fun you know visually with these
ideas of what you can kind of do with
effects and that's clearly all they were
doing because everything else that if
anything added I was eating Ben effect
it's still kind of cool it was it so
cool when the mummy came out I'm still
like well I feel like we've gone like
eight years since Mario Brothers in like
we have an advanced amethyst and I still
just dust face that's it um yeah so
there was concern major concern major
concern from the beginning like which I
guess maybe that was the best thing the
movie did because it did lower our
expectations in the first minute which
is like okay this is an abated switch
the faints which already happened the
trailer looks cool and this movie from
the beginning is pretty bad well and it
was one of those two were you served
watching it and it's not only like you
see bad movies and as a kid you can kind
of tell why they're bad aw it's just
kind of stupid you know cuz this one
happened or that was a dumb thing to say
or something or is it dumb one to say
like with this it was mostly just
confusion like just what what is going
on
I just can't grab just remember saying
going I remember sitting there wondering
what the fuck am I looking at like
because we've been raised on Mario
Brothers since we got our Nintendo
eighty-eight so we had like four or five
years of this stuff we had Super Mario
World already we had a Super Nintendo
and like just you it was unrecognizable
I'm like this looks like something out
of Tim Burton's Batman
this doesn't look but but I wanted that
I was actually okay with that when I saw
because I'm like I because I loved the
Tim Burton Batman said this came out I
think the same year as Batman Returns
and we were around the same yeah it was
he was either I came out either 92 or 93
yeah Batman Returns was 92 yeah and so
and it was kind of the same reaction
except we're with them and returns it
was I don't know how to feel but I'm
leaning towards good if Barbara's was I
don't know how to feel definitely bad
why you know just all the way over to
Bass River to returns is another guilty
pleasure movie and by but that's up that
perfectly it's like I don't know how to
feel but leaning towards kinda like in
where as far a brothers at the time was
like don't know how to feel but I'm
leaning towards this song yeah like this
is definite bad and I mean the funny
thing is we could have been pretty easy
tech let's see 92 or 93 to like if you I
would have known me Eddy I would have
been 13 or 14 when this movie came out
you would have been what a 10 or 11 or
11 or 12 yes I'm like yeah so this
should have been a no-brainer and like I
just remember leaving very confused and
we have already invited you we have
barely enough honey mine I said yeah no
we have very impressionable minds it
even for very impressionable minds it
couldn't get us and that's really tough
and whatever young like like I was just
a young young teenager and you were like
at the perfect age like you know
somewhere between 11 and 12 and like it
was Troy fan art of this I was watching
the trailer over and like I didn't
imagine what kids younger than us
thought cuz I don't remember that there
just wasn't a lot of laughs there wasn't
a lot of just all these kids that's like
them yeah six or seven like you know
you're young kids who went in expecting
super Aria brothers yeah it was just all
of this silence just very confused kind
of silence and I felt worse for them
because we were old enough that we could
move on but that hit they were scarred
for life that had to be pretty bad like
to be raised died you know these
colorful little things in your sixties
every year old Ibaka do I see the movie
like wow there's some movie bitches the
Big Bertha was a giant fish that's all
you dogs just some alley big black baby
yeah spikes under breasts and stuff did
you know connect the lines fuck it it is
how could you not make that connection
oh it's just it's so bizarre these
choices of but even as a goombahs reach
as little mushrooms now they're weird
dinosaur creatures and you know I did am
I did a riff of this at a convention I
think in Canada and it's funny because
when I do I sir go through the same
motions I think most people go through
is that when it starts off it's so
batshit crazy and stupid and idiotic
that you're kind of laughing how bad is
and then you get to the world that gives
you a more batshit crazy and stupid and
then just circus really dull and you're
getting tired of looking at this place
and it's just all foggy account looks
like the breeches you know who veil it's
just unpleasant to look and I bring up
you bring up a good point for a game
that is so colorful I mean when I think
of that that is the one thing about
Nintendo that they always had the kind
of market on me which is bright colorful
distracting games I get every bucket are
you noting like your Vega Xbox Sony get
all the darken gritty games but but
Nintendo was always kind of
family-friendly and like yeah big brain
Costa MacDonald yeah so there's a place
for that you know everyone's why you run
I want something goofy and that's you
know pooped panting Lee easy like like a
two-year-old could play this but it's
fun and like the old Mario games are
like that all you do is jump and throw
little fireballs and and that's it and
to just take something so simple in like
nowhere a turn I like this dark Tim
Burton world and isn't it and not even
make that bad interesting yeah and just
make it so so coalesce and kind of
lifeless but then like at the end people
start getting into again and laughing
cuz all the crazy shit comes back at the
clayey there in the mario outfits and
the one thing that was kind of cool when
I was doing the riff is that not even
laughing no no or maybe I did I think I
said you know when they finally get the
outfits on the red and the green cuz by
God color you know yeah Holly got color
like I said and here we go an hour into
the film and we actually have this areas
like an hour attendance interval we
finally have a Super Mario Bros people
legitimately applauded they're like yes
by God and there is just still such a
connection to see we want to see the
Mario Brothers on the big screen that
even videos on like what's on whatever a
a Puerto Rican and the British man about
far away from Italian as you can get and
not even brothers but following sense if
it's like you just you saw them for a
second sec okay that's just
besides the probably it's like these
portrayed gonna major it's an origin
story and it's like can you imagine can
you imagine sitting through Batman or
spider-man or even Superman and they
don't put on their costumes to about the
last 15 minutes of the movie can you
take a sick form you know even daredevil
which we've been sitting through he's
running around at kicking ass at least
but like most of Mario Brothers they're
just kind of running around there's not
a lot of ass-kicking like it is Cuba I'm
sorry I'm really getting rough copy
about you son of a bitch she's clearly I
got it right before I'm just forgetting
that but hey that's all right
interrupted you I forgot what was this
thing alright so you know Leguizamo was
Italian so that's great they got that
but to get a British guy to be you know
Mario you know doesn't make sense but
you can I'm thinking I'm pretty sure
like was amo is Dutch that is a Dutch
lab
he looks dodge Oh probably German absurd
um but you know in the same thing boat
the city of Aleppo zombo's whatever I
see him it's like I'm sure this guy's
Got Talent cuz I've seen him act serious
and dramatic and he's in the right movie
I love John Leguizamo but he's one of
those workers I even like him in this
but that's is cuz he just doesn't give a
yeah you could say he just looks beaten
down like just say the lines you son of
a bitch
like okay the interviews are great cuz
he's like you know you just be like you
know so it provides a little bit you
know the big movie and it's obviously
pretty good look about where and we're
father and son and stuff you know we're
not even brothers so you know it
provides a little bit me think of a
cloud think of fun of your cloud you're
a puppet puppet stick to the script and
it's like he just passionately looks
like I'm saying your dress you could
have won but it took two directors -
yeah a movie like this um oh okay so I
remember I was gonna say but that's an
important point which is as much as this
is a guilty pleasure movie for me I'm
more in love with the idea of watching
it than I ever am actually sitting
through the whole thing
because I have the same problem I'll
watch about the first quarter of it and
be like a zillion goofy and is saying
probably in the middle of the movie
somewhere I get bored and I enjoyed this
movie as it go to pleasure and I still
get bored every time I see it and then
am at last part I suddenly turn on again
so even as a movie that I love to say is
so bad it's good
I still go fast forward like the media
and I know it's just it's just it's like
at some point it's like it oh it's fine
it's des Hopper as Bowser he's not doing
anything but it's like how long can we
watch this guy not do any things like
mud baths who cares
yeah it honestly if it weren't for him
in a troll tho can you imagine how much
worse it would be I I don't know I'm
still trying to grasp what we got but
well so what about that romance you know
between princess and Yosh I'm sure you
do great stuff with that tongue um yeah
Yoshi was pretty much a throwaway Queen
gives color right it is it's almost it's
almost like Super Mario World got
released too late and they're like shit
we got a wreck on this film to throw a
dinosaur in there hey Lance Hendrick
let's Hendrickson you're walking by be
in our movie okay I just say I love the
plumbers and wave right yeah okay you
know I was gonna be the Terminator right
just say your life thought it was Bishop
and aliens just shot up and saying oh
fuck was that about it was probably
filming Millenium
right around them like just started
chase there are t anything better than
this
um but I'm not saying about like was mo
is that he he seems to go for these
really he's kinda like Johnny Depp and
he wants to go for these colorful weird
roles only like a couple of times does
he ever actually do the well is
stupidest body as I do I played that
part fine
he's unrecognizable uh but it turns out
like the really goofy out there crazy
roles I'm trying to think like once I
was like yeah he did that like really
well and I'm that's not like oh my gos
ami you're not funny no he can be funny
but like whatever Moulin Rouge and like
um Eddie is friggin from an Juliet um
but like I just always for like the past
or something like that like it goes
freeze crazy and like a sketch show for
a while I think Dinny what seem to start
like a sketch show or maybe not I
thought he was I'm just gonna let you
keep going with this John Leguizamo love
and says you know because when he done
no kids he can act and I'll even argue
most of the time does but he clearly for
a while I just had this thing I want the
crazy role I want to be the wacky guy
cuz I don't wanna be just the
good-looking guy I want to be like
really crazy and really wild and fair
enough a lot of people who the hell
knows about what is being offered
you know how Hollywood works it's like
the casting directors in Hollywood and
directors in general give one image of a
person that's it you ruined for life
you're always playing this character but
no it's just fine because he's a
legitimately
like he can do drama very well um you
know and I totally buy it and we wanting
a Wow DJ just heard his name and they're
like that sounds like a silly Russian
name what really cast wha
so oh the fuck else do you say about
this movie it's it's almost one of those
where it's like there's so much to talk
about it's hard to even grasp something
but it's just like too much to take in
oh just for me it's all Dennis Hopper he
is both the best of the worst thing
about it he's just amazing to watch and
ER your pizza's late you know your
pizza's here not now looks like I went
we're abandoning this job we we did
three build-up can you get dry reference
it's like 12 people wrote the script
Madeline style and they didn't have
punchlines for half the jokes it's like
all right but I'm not done writing this
joke who cares headed sighs and then
they pick up where the other one left
off not knowing that there was an
unfinished row will give it a land
entrance and later
um yeah I'm Hugh mervy do you think he
put that on his demo reel for a show
like millennium or something like okay
let's let's see some of your work yeah
like you know what you could just skip
over them if you could the legacy is now
Christian Bale's Batman apparently oh
but yeah it's um for a film that for a
cure that's all the trailer to Batman
Forever and when it came out I was like
hey that's how impressionable my mind
was to nuts or you declared Batman
Forever the best Batman I don't know if
I said yeah you did
I am I did cuz that's another one I
never forgave you my eye shadow a
spider-man 3 and X 3 I anytime you see a
302 movie in a trilogy I never believed
in you ever no but I have come around to
acknowledge that Batman 3 is you know
like I don't like it
now that really was like I was just so
sorry thankfully we had Batman and Robin
so at least it's not as embarrassing
yeah um but yeah but like um but but
yeah for a mind that like fell for
Batman Forever when it came out like you
could show me anything and I will love
it I was so hyped up for the film not
even to grab me at that age what's
impressive it is impressively bad huh
that's what I guess I just don't get
because listen I'm not saying it would
have been great but you could have Care
Bear do this you could have done some
cheap knockoff film with just a semi an
amazing story you farted out at best and
aimed it for six-year-olds and gotten
away with it well they deal with the
show I mean we have a show not just you
could have just done a better animated
version of the show you know and gotten
away with it but to like to to do this
it's you know it is I think it's just
unbridled hubris
ambition unchecked that like now you're
gonna take this shit seriously Super
Mario Brothers earn no game and I just
the arrogance you could do that and it
just blows my mind life is the fact that
the fact that I did get a little kid I'm
gonna fall for anything but yeah just
the fact that couldn't even get into it
that bad age I mean so ready to see this
film so ready to fall for it I'm like
trick me fool me I am your pawn and you
still couldn't get he was he had the
movie poster I had the poster I did
drawings everywhere I mean I was is one
of those like I would you know losses
you know I wonder who that characters
over that he still had the poster up
like three years later as if like he'd
been betrayed he was still waiting to
believe that time I wasn't all alive
just oh I think that your stress out
during the post or even the poster looks
amazing I mean it's just then standing
against an N it's about its
unimaginative you can give us Jews ons
drawing just made it amazing and it's
like oh oh
Stuart's still recovering from it uh so
yeah that's all I got
a Nageotte scoop ah boom Boz gone Goomba
that movie so much
monkey see you later alligator